Workforce identity Federation allows you
to set up an identity pool to use a
third-party identity provider or IDP for
short
for allowing access to resources in your
company's Google Cloud
today we're going to learn how to set up
this identity pool using some of the
core parts of Workforce identity
Federation
before we get started you will have to
set up your Google Cloud organization
identify your billing slash quota
project enable the identity and access
management or IAM for short and resource
apis and install and initialize the
Google Cloud CLI
foreign
we'll start off at the documentation for
configuring Workforce identity
Federation which you can find a link to
in the description
you've already got our organization set
up so let's identify our billing quota
project I'm using the integrated Cloud
shell which already has the Google Cloud
CLI ready to go but you can use
whichever way to use the CLI that you
are most comfortable with use the gcloud
config set billing slash quota
underscore project command to set the
correct project by changing project
underscore ID to your project
I've changed it to wf-pool stash testing
which we'll be using for this video
now let's make sure the IAM and Resource
Management apis are enabled for a
project in the documentation we can just
click the button which will take us to
the page that takes us through the
process first make sure it's enabling
the apis for the correct project then
click next the screen should now say you
are about to enable the IAM and Resource
Management apis click enable after a
brief moment it will finish and you can
close the tab to go back to where we
were
before we move on you'll need the
permissions to configure Workforce
identity Federation ask your
administrator to Grant you the workforce
identity pool admin IAM role role IAM
dot Workforce pool admin on your
organization
now let's configure the workforce
identity pool we'll use the gcloud CLI
gcloud IAM Workforce Dash pools create
command along with our desired pool name
organization ID and a description of the
pool in IAM allow policies you reference
the pool by its name so it is
recommended that you give it a name that
clearly describes the identities it
contains
foreign
that's it the pool is created but now we
need to create a Workforce identity pool
provider
uh wif pool provider is an entity that
describes a relationship between your
Google Cloud organization and your
identity provider
Waf works with idps that support oidc or
saml 2.0 and it is a little different
for each we have documentation for both
as well as documentation on how to set
up Workforce identity Federation with
providers like Azure active directory or
OCTA I'll go over how to create a pool
provider for oidc the steps for saml are
very similar and the documentation can
help you see the differences
in your oidc IDP register a new
application for Google Cloud Workforce
identity Federation note the client ID
and issuer URI provided by the identity
provider you use them in the next steps
to create an oidc IDP you'll use the
gcloud IAM Workforce Dash pools provider
create-oidc command and provide it with
the provider id the workforce pool ID
issuer URI client ID which we registered
with the IDP earlier attribute mapping
and attribute condition optionally you
can also provide a display name and a
description
now that the pool and its provider are
set up we need to be able to represent
the users of this pool in the IAM
policies for the project you can use
identifiers to Grant roles to a single
user a group of users users carrying a
particular claim or all users from a
Workforce pool to do this use the gcloud
projects
add-iam- policy Dash binding command
along with your project the role and the
principal identifier you are binding it
to I'll bind the storage admin role to
anyone in the pool now that our identity
pool and provider are set up we need to
configure our pool so it can get a
credential token when a user logs in to
do this use the gcloud IAM Workforce
Dash pools
create-cred-config command there are
slight differences for both oidc and
saml 2.0 supporting idps and whether you
are using file sourced URL sourced or
executable sourced credentials
for my needs I'm using file Source
credentials from my oidc supporting
identity provider so all I'll need to
provide is the workforce pool ID the
provider id the path to the file where
the credential token is and the
workforce pool project
you should now have everything set up to
make sure run the gcloud auth login
command and point it to the config file
generated from the last step as you can
see everything is working correctly in
my project
for most projects you'll be building
your own login portal if you use a
supported client Library you can
configure the client Library so that it
generates Google credentials
automatically when possible we recommend
that you generate credentials
automatically so that you don't need to
implement the token exchange process
yourself
spending time with me today learning how
to set up identity pools and identity
pool providers we also cover the
configuration setups that you might use
depending on your provider to find out
more about how to set up and configure
Workforce identity Federation follow the
links in the description for this video
or search for Workforce identity
Federation at cloud.google.com
foreign
[Music]